let's bring in Doug Gottlieb fox sports
radio host Fox Sports college basketball
analyst hi Doug how are you I'm well Dan
glad you're healthy glad the man cave I
know you're Manning the man cave by
yourself but good to see it it's fun to
be able to actually shoot basketball
that's like to have at least a place
where you can go and I you know I love
shooting basketball by myself so this is
a perfect time for me I don't have to
share the ball and I see the basketball
hoop in the background there with you
yeah well listen uh because I performed
so poorly in the old man cave we I mean
that's this is not for me to be able to
compete with you in the man cave that's
the only reason then I talked to dr.
douche and I bought this thing second
constantly get shots up yesterday was a
good day yesterday was a good day and
I'll be ready next time I get the call
to come wait now you're working on your
shot in it late like dad yesterday we do
sets of make 50 and it took me like 86
to make 50 threes whatever and so he's
like dad yeah you're on fire today I was
like yeah
don't tell anybody now and poor Eddie
Sutton he's probably gonna know now Doug
cares about his jump shot yeah well I
wouldn't take him so long to get in the
hole all right let me start with the G
League here and coach Calipari is among
some of the coaches who talked about
this as you know this is gonna be bad
you're gonna have thousands of kids who
are going to envision this what do you
think is the real real here with the G
League with these kids coming out of
high school just wanting to go be a
professional basketball player well look
I think what Coach Cal is saying is 100%
accurate it's not the five kids that
we're gonna go overseas and didn't want
to go to college
those ones those kids aren't the problem
the problem is the hundred other kids
that think they're one of the top five
kids
and so are they gonna do the work right
to put themselves in position to go to
college if the g-league thing doesn't
work out additionaly like always we've
had so many people to say like man we
need the baseball system like the people
understand how many people will wash out
in the baseball system and oh yeah by
the way those baseball guys they may get
a good payment up front but once you
become a major league baseball player
you don't really get paid until you're
fourth or fifth year you know our become
arbitration eligible so there's a it's
just a completely different system yeah
you know me Dan I've maybe I'll die on
this hill
there's nothing wrong with going to
college and I actually think that you
know you had Roy Williams on and he was
great but the had Michael Jordan not
gone to North Carolina would he be
Michael Jordan and again we don't know
there's no control group there right and
and while the age old line is Dean
Smith's the only guy to be able to hold
Michael Jordan below 20 points it was
all of those other things that Michael
Jordan learned to do well and then once
he got to the NBA now his true gifts and
skill came out along with the fact that
he defended he was a good teammate he
knew how to live on his own he knew how
to be a good you know he he had gone
through the maturity a stage where
you're away from home but you're not
that far away from home like when he was
in chapel like I think all these things
are important so look this is what the
NBA is gonna try I don't understand how
you're gonna sign up for a massive money
loser you know right like that's the big
thing and if we look around sports mild
league baseball what is it 40 minor
league baseball or zatia are losing
their affiliations this is a money loser
for the NBA I don't like the Academy
system because while it may refine a guy
skill for the NBA it doesn't teach him
the value of winning of dominating guys
at your age it doesn't allow you to play
in front of crowds there's there's a
bunch of stuff you're missing and so I
don't love it but I guess it's what's
going to happen and I just I wonder how
many kids they're gonna take and how
many other kids
it affects because they think they're
one of the elite kids
supply and demand you can have
aspirations to play in the G League and
make that money but that somebody has to
take you it's you know how many guys
have the aspirations to play in the NBA
there's only so many roster spots there
only so many kids who are going to get
this special deal I'm fine with it I
applaud it if you want to be a
professional player and this is a gap
year get paid for it and I can have
professionals working with you on and
off the court and that's what you want
to do then don't take up a roster spot
in college no no listen listen this is
the the the dirty little secret that no
one will admit is this has it this has
been there for high school kids since
they started the back window is the
d-league yeah you were allowed to go
straight from high school to the
d-league the difference was the the
level of compensation right and don't
start with me with the knot you just the
well they can go and they're gonna pay
for their education first of all none of
these kids are gonna go to college
second of all once they get done playing
if they want to go to college you may be
able to pay for them to go to college
but they can't get in they get in
because as you know having kids that
have gone through college how difficult
it is to get in on your own because
they'll be they'll be on their own so
this is simply becoming a professional
this is what we've had a lot of pundits
like like Jay Bilas say hey this should
this should be available now everything
will be available for these kids and
let's see if it actually makes one the
product better and two it makes the kids
better I also I I do think Jason
Whitlock brought this up remember Steve
Kerr wrote a piece back when he was a
broadcaster about how he thinks it's bad
for the product that's one of the things
that's missing here you know is that is
that it is bad for the product because
when guys are what one-and-done or none
and done and you don't have the
promotion of the NCAA tournament
we don't know who they are so following
four kids you can tell me their YouTube
sensations or whatever but if there's
when we watch guys think you remember
when when Pat Ewing came to the pros
everyone knew who Pat Ewing was all
these guys became household names
because of the NCAA tournament because
of college basketball and so you're
losing that promotion factor that all
the major networks buy into I think
there's a lot of things that are gonna
get lost in it and I guess we'll just
have to wait and see how it works
if
pans out and and if there are I mean
half the NBA stars are late bloomers
what happens to those guys and do we
lose any sort of value with Colin fast
hey it's great to talk to you as always
great job on the afternoons there on the
Fox Sports Radio lineup do you want to
try to hit a shot right now on TV can I
do that see here can you position your
camera and let's see Doug Gottlieb
joining us from a very wealthy
neighborhood here oh yeah by the way by
the way just the the Cavs did
double-team Jordan on the important
poorly I mean look go back and watch
Michael Jordan used his hands he pushed
yes okay I know I can't let him have the
ball and if I let him have the boys
gonna have no he's got to get in the
backcourt you can't go in the backcourt
in the NBA rules I believe at the time
so yes you're look you're right full
face full face star denial
don't let him get the basketball Larry
Nance and Craig Ehlo there's a lot to
get into there I agree with you that
that there's some revisionist history
right so how do I marry each other are
you delaying your shot now okay here I
am not I'm not
you got it what I hoped you had a little
backup I got just one hand
oh that's short are they short let's see
one more this is a slanted driveway yeah
the safety driveway though it's gonna
help him with his arch honey shot I made
that you know no I say the second one
missed the first one like my free throw
like my free throw percentage are hey
hey one last thing Dan you you have to
go you have to go well we have to stop
this nonsense about the Packers somehow
disrespecting Aaron Rodgers they gave
him more money than any player in the
history of the sport just last year they
can't cut him or trade him for at least
two years probably three years all they
did was protect themselves so that when
Aaron Rodgers ages as he's begun to do
they have the heir apparent because
they're never going to draft in the top
ten because Aaron Rodgers that's it
if you want me to help your son shooting
I'll be more than happy to send some
videos maybe a zoom job we can do yeah
we do a zoom chat little YouTube I'd be
more than happy to do a tutorial with
your son what's your hourly what's your
hourly rate it's it's a master's class
just like Steph Curry did it's the same
thing this is just to get back to the
kids Doug it's not about money Doug it's
just given back to the kids
he's available after his in-house school
later on by the way anything that being
said it's a thousand dollars no no I put
on my tab thank you thank you doing
that's a Doug Gatlin